good afternoon we've done a lot of work
with with vectors and in a lot of the
problems when we launched something into
you know in the projectile motion
problems or when you were doing the the
inclined plane problems we always broke
you know I always gave you a vector like
I would draw a vector like this I would
say you know something is has a velocity
of 10 meters per second it's at a
30-degree angle
and then I would break it up into the
X&Y components so you know if I called
this vector V I would use a notation V
sub X and you know the V sub X would
have been this vector right here V sub X
would have been this vector down here
the X component of the vector and then V
sub y would have been the Y component of
the vector and it would you know it
would have been this vector so this was
V sub X this is V sub y right and
hopefully by now at second nature of how
we would figure these things out V sub X
would be 10 times cosine of this angle
10 cosine of 30 degrees which I think is
square root of 3 over 2 but we're not
worried about that right now and V sub y
would be 10 times the sine of that angle
this hopefully should be second nature
to you if it's not you can just go
through sohcahtoa and and say well the
sine of 30 degrees is the opposite of
the hypotenuse and you would get back to
this but we've reviewed all of that and
you should review the initial vector
videos but what I want you to do now
because this is useful for a simple
projectile motion problem but once we
start dealing with more complicated
vectors and maybe we're dealing with
multi dimensional vectors three
dimensional vectors or we start doing
linear algebra where we do n dimensional
vectors we need a coherent way of an
analytical way instead of having to
always draw a picture of representing
vectors so what we do is we use
something that I call up and I think
everyone calls unit vector notation so
what does that mean so we define these
unit vectors let me draw some axes it's
important to keep in mind this might
seem a little confusing at first but
this is no different than what we've
been doing in in our physics problem so
far so let me draw the ax
these draw the axes right there let's
say that this this is this is 1 this is
0 this is X well sorry what am i doing
this is 2 0 1 2 out of nose must have
been writing in Arabic or something
going backwards but it's a 0 1 2 that's
not 220 and then let's say that this is
1 this is 2 in the Y Direction I'm going
to define what I call the unit vectors
in two dimensions so I'm going to first
define a vector I will call this vector
I and if this is the vector it just goes
from it just goes straight in the X
direction it has no y component and it
has a magnitude of 1 and so this is I
and we donate we denote the unit vector
by putting this little cap on top of it
there's multiple notation sometimes in a
book you'll see this eye without the cap
and it's just boldface there are some
other notations but if you see I and
then not in the imaginary number sense
you should realize that that's the unit
vector it has magnitude 1 and it's
completely in the X direction and I'm
going to define another vector and that
one is called J and that is the same
thing but in the Y direction that is the
vector J and you put a little cap over
it so why did I do this well if I'm
dealing with two dimensions and as later
we'll see in three dimensions it will
actually be a third dimension and we'll
call that K but don't worry about that
right now but if we're dealing in in two
dimensions we can we can define any
vector in terms of some sum sum of these
two vectors so how does that work well
what this vector here let's call it V
right this vector V is the sum of its X
component plus its Y component right
when you add vectors you can put them
head to tail like this and that's the
sum so hopefully knowing what we already
know we knew that the vector V is equal
to its X component its X component plus
its Y component
when you add vectors you essentially
just put them head to tails and then the
the resulting sum is kind of where you
end up right so would be if you added
this vector and then you put this tail
to this head and you end up there so you
end up there so that's the vector so can
we define V sub X as some multiple of I
of this of this unit vector well sure V
sub X completely goes in the X direction
right but it's it doesn't have a
magnitude of 1 it has a magnitude of 10
cosine of 30 degrees so its magnitude is
10 so this is let me draw the unit
vector up here this is the unit vector I
it's going to look something like this
and this so V sub X it's in the exact
same direction and it's just a scaled
version of this unit vector and what's
its what multiple is it of that of that
unit vector
well the unit vector has a magnitude of
1 this has a magnitude of 10 cosine of
30 degrees so I think that's what like
five square roots of three or something
like that so we can write V sub X as we
could write V sub X I keep switching
colors to keep things interesting we can
write V sub X is equal to ten cosine of
30 degrees times that's the degrees
times the unit vector I let me stay in
that color so you don't get confused
times the unit vector I does that make
sense
well the unit vector I goes in the exact
same direction but the the X component
of this vector is just a lot longer it's
10 cosine 30 degrees long and I can you
know that's equal to cosine of 30
degrees is square root of 3 over 2 so
that's five square roots of three I
similarly we can write we can write the
Y component of this vector is some
multiple of J is some multiple of J so
we could say V sub y the y component
well what is sine of 30 degrees sine of
30 degrees is 1/2
so 1/2 times 10 so this is 5 so the
y-component goes completely in the
y-direction so it is just going to be a
multiple of this vector J of the unit
vector J and what multiple is it well it
has it has length 5 while the unit
vector has just length 1 so it's just 5
times the unit vector J so how can we
write the vector V well we know the
vector V is the sum of its X component
in its Y component and we also know so
this is a hole vector V what's its X
component well its X component can be
written as a multiple of the X unit
vector that's that right there so you
can write it as 5 square roots of 3 I
plus its Y component so what's its Y
component well its Y component is just a
multiple of the Y unit vector which is
called J with the little funny hat on
top and that's just this it's 5 times J
so we've done now by defining these unit
vectors and I can switch this color just
so you remember this is I that this unit
vector is this is using unit vectors in
two dimensions and we can eventually do
them in multiple dimensions we can
analytically express any two-dimensional
vector instead of having to always draw
it like we did before and having to
break out its components and always do
it visually we can stay in kind of
analytical mode and non graphical mode
and what makes this very useful is that
if I have if I can write a vector in
this format I can add them and subtract
them without having to resort to resort
to visual means and what do I mean by
that let me so if I have you know if I
define some vector a is equal to I don't
know 2i plus 3j and I have some other
event this is a vector and I have some
other vector B this little arrow just
means it's a vector sometimes you'll see
it as a whole arrow sum as
Oh ten-eye plus I don't know 2j if I
were to say what's what's what's the sum
of these two vectors a plus B before we
had this unit vector notation we would
have to draw them and put them heads to
tails and it didn't you have to do it
visually new take you a lot of time but
once you have it broken up into the x
and y components you can just separately
add the x and y components so vector A
plus vector B that's just 2 plus 10
times I plus 3 plus 2 times J and that's
equal to 12 I plus 5 J and something you
might want to do a maybe I'll do it in a
future video is actually draw out these
two vectors and add them visually and
you'll see that you get this exact
answer and as we go into further videos
or future videos you'll see how this is
super useful once we start doing more
complicated physics problems or once we
start doing physics with calculus anyway
I'm about to run out of time for on the
10 minutes so I'll see you in the next
video